the storm clouds have been permanently
affixed over the head
of matt patricia now the third year head
coach of the lions
um
let's hear from patricia given all of
the pressure that he's under in giving
all of the calls that are out there for
his job to be the next one to end as an
nfl head coach
certainly i think when i came to detroit
there was a lot of work to do and that's
what we're trying to do um but uh you
know talking about this year right now
we're talking about right now in uh you
know these first four games and
obviously today wasn't good enough i
think after four games you know our team
can really take a look at itself and say
okay hey how do we need to play the
games what we got to do we got some work
to do during the bye week here i think
which will be good for us to really take
a look at how do we need to play going
forward and i think that's probably the
most important thing from that
standpoint is what do we do going
forward um and how do we win
that claim by patricia there was a lot
of work to do when i got here
that has opened the door to some sharp
criticism of patricia because in a
roundabout way it throws shade at jim
caldwell his predecessor and here's the
reality when bob quinn became the gm and
it's funny his name doesn't come up in
any of this when bob quinn became the gm
first order of business
was to hire matt patricia
but
he didn't want to throw jim caldwell
overboard
too quickly he wanted to give caldwell a
chance well he won the division or at
least made it to the playoffs didn't win
the division they won the division in
forever as far as i can remember but
well forever's a long time at some point
they won the division i think but they
didn't win the division that year but
they got to the playoffs then caldwell
got one more year
and he was still competitive and that's
when he got fired so that's the problem
and this was a point that came up last
night when we were discussing the lions
uh the set of football night in america
and tony dungy and i were considering
whether to what extent there was a bad
culture before patricia got there
there really wasn't
and so patricia comes in with all these
bill belichick style changes whether he
intends to or not it's part of your dna
when you're with belichick for 15 years
you think you're doing it your way
you're doing it the way that you just
think is normal because you've been
around bill belichick players are going
to resist it and when it wasn't a 2 and
14 team a perennial loser you know yeah
they haven't won a playoff game in in
nearly 30 years but it's not like
they're they're horrible every single
season it makes it harder for the
players to accept it shireen and now
we're at a point where you've got to
have the results you can't bring the
belichick dna to town and not have
results and that's the problem for the
detroit lions and the question is will
that claim matt patricia's job during or
after this season
yeah nine and seven in jim caldwell's
last year they are now 10 25 and one
under matt patricia they cannot hold the
lead glover glover quinn weighed in on
matt patricia's statement today saying
don't start that mess this was a nine
and seven team when you took over and it
was and you look at the players that
have gone since then darius slay and
quinn and quandary diggs and you go on
and on and on i was fooled into thinking
this was a team ready to turn the corner
with matt stafford coming back and
stafford's regressed he does not look
good with with this team with this coach
with this coaching staff for whatever
reason whether it's he missed games last
year whatever
to me he is not the same quarterback he
was under jim caldwell and i thought he
was ready to really turn the corner have
an mvp
like season in his last season with
caldwell and now here we go again and
hear the lions muddling through yet
another season and you know the pressure
was on he and quinn both before the year
started but now they've had a change in
leadership at the top of the up at the
top of the organization and sheila
fordham who's now in charge and and
whether she sees changes are necessary
or not after this season we'll see
but they were put on notice before this
year started
or during that's the thing once the
first domino falls the question becomes
will there be others will it happen in
detroit will it happen with the jets the
jets just had an opportunity mini buy on
the back end of a thursday night game
they didn't make a move on adam gase
they've got six more games before their
bye week if they go into that by owen 10
who knows what happens and this is
the
the bottom line we can speculate and we
can talk and we can analyze and we can
guess and we can hear things that may or
may not be accurate but you never know
what's going to happen until that one
individual
who's got his or her hands
on
the wheel of the car decides where it's
going to be driven cal mcnair decided
that it's time for bill o'brien to go of
all the coaches out there who
are in some degree of trouble he would
have been the last one i expected to go
i would thought patricia i would have
thought gase
so it just tells you that you got to be
ready for anything
anytime anyplace anywhere an owner can
decide i'm going to do something and
shireen i don't want to get too far
afield here that's one of the reasons
why
and because it'd be good it could be
good and it can be bad
one of the reasons that the packers are
such a unicorn in the nfl they don't
have that one person
who can decide at any given moment you
know what i'm firing the head coach it
doesn't work that way with a publicly
traded
company that has boards of directors and
yeah mark murphy's in charge but he just
can't he just can't say i you know he's
got somebody to answer to everybody else
who's running a team has someone to
answer to accept the teams that are
owned by individuals and they can say
that's it i'm done so it can happen at
any time
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports